New research says the more intense the lighting
in a room is, the more intense your emotions
are- and not just the positive ones.
Anthony Carboni here for DNews and to a certain
extent this seems obvious- we hear all the
time about sunnier days making us happy and
darker, grayer, dimmer winters making people
sad.
A team from the University of Toronto Scarborough
found kind of an interesting paradox, though.
Depressed people didn't get happier on sunny
days.
They got more depressed.
So the team ran some studies and found that
all emotions are more intense under bright
lights.
We just FEEL more when it's brighter.
The team asked people to rate certain things
in a brightly or dimly lit room - the spiciness
of some chicken wings, how attractive someone
was, how aggressive a fictional character
seemed.
In the brighter room, people thought the chicken
wings were spicier, the woman was more attractive
and that the character more aggressive.
The theory the team lead put forward is that
ambient brightness makes people feel warmer.
Light is perceived as heat by our emotional
system, and heat can trigger emotional responses
in us.
I guess spiciness, sexiness, and anger could
be considered 'hot' emotions, but then what's
a "cold" emotion?
There are a few other takeaways from the team
that I found much more interesting: the first
is that bright light could be intensifying
our initial emotional response to things that
happen to us throughout the day.
So turning down lights before an argument
or emotional conversation might help people
think about it more rationally.
The other is that stores could design their
lighting based on what they're selling: engagement
rings?
Flowers?
Those are emotional decisions- crank up the
lights and let the love come in.
More sensible products?
Lower the lights and let logic take over.
I know I tend to be more productive and motivated
in a bright room- I've never really paid attention
to whether I FEEL any different.
What about you?
Are you more intense in brighter environments?
Let me know down below.
If you watch a lot, you probably noticed I'm
wearing different glasses.
These are from Warby Parker.
They're awesome and they were affordable-
these frames and lenses were $95.
They also have prescription sunglasses for
$125.
They've got a home try-on plan where you go
to their site, pick 5 kinds of frames, they
send 'em to you to try on for free, then you
send them back in a pre-paid mailer.
If you wanna help out DNews and get some sick
glasses go to warbyparker.com/dnews and get
some glasses with free 3-day shipping.
For every pair they sell, they donate another
pair to someone in need.